give me a moment with your friend i've
never been on trial for my thoughts
before
i wanted the courtroom to feel cavernous
and i wanted to sort of feel the full
weight of the federal government coming
down
these guys and the kind of power that
frank langella's character that julius
hoffman
will be doing he's carrying the energy
settling things down
how's that working so far second drafts
are really important a friend of mine
once uh
said about me that uh i don't write
scripts i rewrite scripts
how much is it worth you what's your
price to call off the revolution
my life but uh i didn't change the
script to mirror events
events change to mirror the script you
want to avoid all kinds of stereotypes
not just because of uh racial or ethnic
uh
sensitivity stereotypes are just bad in
uh in writing
you can write heroes you can write
villains but there's no such thing as an
interesting character who doesn't have a
conscience
you're aware that this important story
and people's lives and reputations are
are in your hand movies are very
powerful things they're seen by
a lot of people and that to me was
was the more important truth
one of the things that i looked at a lot
during prep
was protest scenes for me so many times
in film and on television
they don't look real i looked at a bunch
of movies where i thought well they did
a really good job
argo for instance what ben affleck did
with the opening of argo
archival footage news footage stock
footage he cut it together
with very tight shots of people he hit
stage
we do the same i got a couple of wide
shots but
mostly everything is tight just a billy
club hitting a skull
we were able to do that because we were
shooting those protest scenes
in grant park where they took place
after a lot of research because i knew
nothing about the chicago 7 when i
uh started this uh after
reading a dozen or so books that have
been written some of them by
the defendants a 21 000 page trial
transcript
but most critically uh uh the time i
spent with tom hayden who was alive when
i started this he passed away a few
years ago
um uh is that is what
gave me a look into the personal tension
between
tom and abby two guys on the same side
who want the same thing
who plainly can't stand each other and
each thinks that the other
is harming the cause what i was gonna
say was after the research there's the
period of just pacing around and
climbing the walls and trying to figure
out
exactly what story you're going to tell
uh
the film organized itself into three
stories what you just said the
the courtroom drama the
evolution of the riot had in what was
supposed to be a
peaceful protest evolved into such a
violent clash with the police and the
national guard
and then finally this personal story
uh between tom and abby uh and i decided
i'd tell those three stories at the same
time and
hope for the best my advice for uh for
new screenwriters
is this get a hold of a couple of
screenplays
of movies that you like and get a hold
of the dvd
and watch the movie with the screenplay
in your lap and kind of
read along as the movie goes and you can
see what
what what your favorite movies looked
like when they were on the page keep
doing that and you'll start to get the
feel
of of what a screenplay is you walk into
the art department
you would see many many boards of just
the aesthetic of 1968 and 6970 was which
is when the trial happened
the one note that i gave everybody at
the beginning
and then every day after that was don't
lean into 60s iconography
hippies and hard hats the tie-dye peace
sign
psychedelic aesthetic because this movie
is not about 1968 it's about today and i
want to put as little as possible
between the movie and today's
audience shane valentino was our
production designer did
a phenomenal job and his sort of the
crown jewel of his production design
was the courtroom the actual courtroom
where the trial took place
didn't look enough like a courtroom i
was less interested in journalistic
accuracy than the truth of the more
important story that we're telling
i remember the day where he showed me
the different
almost murals that would be on the wall
it was fantastic
i wanted the courtroom to feel cavernous
and i wanted to sort of feel the full
weight of the federal government coming
down
these guys and the kind of power that
frank langella's character that julius
hoffman
wielded caitlyn greenridge says if you
are writing a marginalized character
whose identity you do not share
can you imagine your way into that
character through their joy
and not their imagined trauma yes
uh uh you can empathy uh
right same blood that goes through your
body goes through that person
we all have as humans the power to
empathize with each other uh to
understand each other's lives
and to put any character we want into a
dramatic
situation because the most important
thing in your story
is it going to be someone's sexual
orientation their skin color
their religion whether they are
able-bodied or
disabled the most important thing is in
your story
is going to be intention and obstacle
what does this character want
and what's standing in their way of
getting it and i assume that because
you're interested in telling this story
you are interested in what the character
wants and what's standing in their way
of getting it
or you think it's a great comic premise
with which you can use your sense of
humor
or you think it's a great premise with
wish to tell a murder mystery
or a romantic comedy or anything like
that
but i really think it's important that
writers not start to get cautious
because they're scared of of being
offensive stereotypes should be avoided
whether it's as you say someone from a
diverse population or someone who looks
exactly like you
um you want to avoid all kinds of
stereotypes
not just because of uh racial or ethnic
uh
sensitivity stereotypes are just bad in
uh in writing i can be different in
every possible way
but if that person is a father i'm a
father
if that person is also a father i feel
like i
know everything about them that's
important to know that you can know
uh as a stranger i can empathize with
that person
you don't want to judge that person you
want to defend that person you want to
be able to make that person's case to
god why they should be allowed into
heaven
do not do not do not feel
that you are required to write about
yourself
and your world write about any world you
want you're making the world
uh sorry i don't mean to be yelling you
i'm just i'm passionate about this
uh okay you ma'am are not confined by
any guard rails i've been asked a couple
of times if i change the script at all
to
mirror events and i didn't i rewrote the
script plenty of times in the 14 years
since i was asked to write a movie about
the chicago 7
but just to you know in the normal
process of a
screenwriter rewriting a script to make
it better
including by the way great notes from
paul greengrass and david fincher
uh but uh i didn't change the script to
mirror events
events change to mirror the script uh
look when i
started doing this it was just
a good story to tell um uh i thought
this was
uh uh you know i thought this could be a
good movie and then
things started to change uh a few years
ago
when donald trump uh at his rallies
began to get nostalgic
about the old days when they'd carry
that guy out of here on a stretcher and
i'd like to beat the crap out of them
and
there was um descent was being demonized
and that was the atmosphere that we were
making the film in
uh last winter we thought it was plenty
relevant when we were making it last
winter we didn't need it to get
more relevant uh but then i think it was
in may that george floyd
was killed and brianna taylor and ahmed
arberry
and so protests in kenosha and seattle
and lexington and washington dc and
uh around the country protesters uh were
being
met again by police
nightsticks uh uh tear gas
um and it was a chilling return
to 1968 so like i said we thought the
film was plenty relevant when we were
making it we didn't need it to get more
relevant but it did
when those sound categories come up at
awards shows
i am now very interested in who they are
they are truly unsung heroes
and sound is one of those areas of
filmmaking
where the audience doesn't know that
that was a big reason
why they loved the movie
[Music]
i would give notes like when the phone
rings in the middle of the night and
wakes up hayden and bernadine by this
news that's coming
on the phone i just kind of said that
ring should
sound like you're able to get a couple
of hours sleep for the first night in a
while and just the world is being
cracked open
they're able to take a note like that
and they create it
conspiracy office you ask about the
difference between good and great and
often times it's sound what we were
making with chicago 7
or with molly's game or with charlie
wilson's war the social network of steve
jobs is
a painting and not a photograph because
i don't feel that the important truth is
what size the courtroom was
i feel that the more important truth was
the fact that the justice department
was engaging in politics and eliminating
political enemies
of this newly elected president richard
nixon you're aware that
this important story and people's lives
and reputations are are in your hand
movies are very powerful things they're
seen by a lot of people
and that to me was uh was the more
important
truth now uh aaron 2020 has been one for
the books i'm curious does watching a
year like this
play out make you want to write about it
and what would the finale look like
please tell me it won't be revenge of
the murder hornets
uh it wouldn't be if i wrote it uh i
think but uh listen a lot will be
written about these
uh about these last few years uh by
screenwriters and by playwrights but
uh my my prediction is that you'll never
see donald trump as an on-screen
character that will always be off-screen
that you'll see him
on televisions and news footage because
he's simply implausible
as a character uh and i you
you can write heroes you can write
villains but there's no such thing as an
interesting character who doesn't have a
conscience
i've been watching your work be directed
by
some of the greatest filmmakers of all
time for years rob reiner obviously
david
david fincher doing social network danny
boyle's brilliant work
on steve jobs miller's work on uh
moneyball
um and i wonder as you were watching
these films become the movies they were
based on your screenplays what elements
of those directors
and the way they approached your
material
changed the way how you become the
filmmaker you are today i mean are there
things you can pinpoint
from specific films or directors that
you go all right that director really
approached my material this way and that
influenced the director that i became
on this film and molly's game yeah i
would say and also added to the
list of directors you named mike nichols
and tommy in television as the principal
director of the west wing
uh you would have to really not be
paying attention
uh to stand next to these guys
for uh for as long as i was able to
stand next to them and not pick up
anything uh so
uh
so i i i try to um well i try to steal
as much from them uh as i can
uh i i i've watched the way they work
um and i either think uh well that's
that's a shoe i could
fit into or you know that's that's not
how i would
uh i want to work um mostly what i try
to pay attention to
is stuff that speaks to my blind spot
a literal blind spot which is that i
have a very
weak visual sensibility um i i've
spent my life paying attention to how
movies television shows and plays
sound uh and not as much attention to
how they look
um but i'm told that
uh a visual element in cinema
is important to some people um
so i'm trying to get better at that was
there something specifically from
fincher
um like on social networks specifically
that you learned
yes but in the way a
freshman uh would pick up a little
something
from a guy who's teaching a phd
course in something like you could sit
in the class and maybe you could pick up
a couple of things
but there's so much you have to learn
before you can
understand what what he's talking about
with david
i'm talking about specifically the care
he puts into uh creating a frame
uh you know i've i've seen him spend
hours uh on an exterior shot
trying to get just a little spill of
light from a street lamp that's
two blocks away
[Laughter]
and you know i would think to myself at
the time boy i
don't know if this really makes that
much difference this
spill of life and then i'll look at a
shot of mine that really could have used
a spell of life
so i'm learning the hard way but i'm
learning all right holly jack
uh people who write stuff how do you
approach second drafts
blank page and start again amendments to
what you've already got any thoughts
tips would be appreciated
yeah great second drafts are really
important friend of mine once uh said
about me that
i don't write scripts i rewrite scripts
and here's what he meant
in the process of writing the first
draft by the time you get to the end
you've sort of discovered what the movie
is about
uh because it may not end up that first
draft being about
what you thought it was going to be
about when you started writing it you
plotted a course to go due north
but as you were going you started going
a little bit
east and then a little bit more east and
and when you end up you're
you're going northeast so you've figured
out uh what the script is about it's
probably fat
it's probably long go back to the
beginning of the script
start writing it over again peel away
the things that don't have anything to
do with your story
hang a lantern on the things that you
need to bring into relief
uh in the story you're gonna discover
that
a problem that you have in the third act
isn't really in the third act it's
because you didn't set it up properly in
the first
so second drafts i say
re-type the whole thing sharpen up that
joke that's kind of clunky sharp enough
that's
that dialogue that's kind of clunky get
it down to its fighting weight
that's what i do anyway thanks a lot for
the question
you